bucyk oh there we go
okay it's a lip Friday night gonna say
we get a lip you're welcome are you a
dog person or a cat person I always grew
up with both dogs and cats and so I
would say I'm most comfortable with a
house full of all of them Oh what is
your favorite thing to do on a Friday
night after work
Posey don't well actually that's pretty
easy she knows the answer to that
question I go home and wait for my wife
to come home from work and we make a
nice meal we open a bottle of wine we
sit in front of the fireplace and we
listen to old music from the 70s and 80s
from when we were in school and we sit
there and try and outdo each other about
who can come up with the coolest song
from our past my kids they walk around
behind us but it doesn't suck it's like
journey and air supply and kiss and
blondie it's good stuff it's a lip
Friday I didn't say we get lips get a
bottle of wine and we sit by the fire
five reasons why you love Kevin Smith
five reasons I love Kevin Smith Cavan
and Kevin are very close together I like
his name he's a funny guy I mean I
really hope he doesn't see this when it
airs but I think he's a funny guy okay
after he's pretty good actor as well he
cooks apparently he has cooked for me
yet but apparently he's a great cook and
he's a family man
hello there and I kind of talked about
his family and I kind of dig that you
know he's gonna salt of the earth family
family I like that about 1 2 3 4 5 my
question for the next person is simple
how much would kind of a chuck if a
woodchuck could chuck what how much wood
would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck
would chuck wood uh-huh
how much well the answer to that is very
easy the answer is because all the wood
chuck does his check would and he's
never stopping if you were coming
through Hope Valley and stopped to have
a conversation with some of the town
folk and your horse took a plot in the
middle of the street do you think you
would acknowledge it or ignore it if I
was in a conversation and my horse plops
I would definitely acknowledge it maybe
apologize because I'm Canadian I
apologize for the horse doing its thing
that's so natural and then I would
excuse myself to go clean it up my
question for you is what did you have
for breakfast and what do you want the
wood okay Kayla what did I have for
breakfast I'm gonna be really honest I
had a reheated double baked almond
croissant from small victory bakery
which is really weird because I fast
most mornings but this morning I went to
get me a coffee and I smelled the almond
croissant and I'm like what we compared
it with my coffee then this almond
croissant reheated in the oven what am I
gonna have for lunch always tons of
veggies as many veggies as I can get on
the plate with olive oil on them and
stuff and then some kind of if they
don't have fish then I don't know I
don't eat meat so sometimes have a
little bit of fish would you rather swim
in that Lake the man-made beautiful pond
out there for 90 seconds you got to go
in it when it's cold or eat the pickled
deviled egg from the mercantile
there's one season one you're welcome if
I had the choice between jumping into
the Hope Valley Lake in November or
consuming one of the pickled eggs in the
mercantile both of which are not great
options I would definitely have to go
with jumping in the lake because I I
don't I don't think I could stomach it
pick those things have been there for
years and by the way being a pregnant
actress I would not be consuming
something that has been sitting on a
shelf as a prop for so many years we
will absolutely be jumping in the
November cold waters what is your least
favorite dish to eat at the cafe in Hope
Valley I think my least favorite thing
to eat at the cafe would have to be the
chicken pot pie so usually when we are
in there there there is food there for
us to eat but the actors do a lot of
fake eating we just don't want to risk
it with food that's been sitting out
four or five hours or longer so we just
do them I mean with the fork actually
you know who's very good at is cabin
very good mm-hmm mm-hmm
garlic nice magnitude if we planned a
murder-mystery party the cast of one
calls the heart who would have done it
if there was going to be a burden
mystery party who think the killer would
have been me I mean no because any
question about that that's just
happening I mean come on I've made my
career at a bad guy in a suit I'm
totally the killer it definitely has to
be me it's my body count is ridiculous
and I'm definitely the killer if you
were gonna person into drag diva who
would be
of course you would ask that of course
you would if I had to portray a drag
diva it would be Meryl Streep they'll
clean right there I have this little
game I've been doing for the last four
Halloween's where originally I was
supposed to go with a group of my
friends we're all gonna be different
characters of male Street but they all
bailed so every Halloween I'm a
different character male Streep who
played so it fits perfectly for me I'm
already doing it so there you go
last year was her from doubt I was her
than none and the year before that was
Margaret Thatcher or that was Julia
Child if you had to choose someone on
our cast other than who your card up
with who'd you choose to be your love
interest well thank you for that
question Erin if I could choose someone
as Elizabeth's love interest other than
Nathan or Lucas I would choose the great
love of her life
baby Joe and would only be interested in
loving
[Music]